Les américains devaient
retourner sur la Lune en 2024.
C'est raté parce que la nouvelle
génération de combinaisons
spatiales, un élément vital
du programme lunaire, n'est
toujours pas au point.
Pourtant, le développement des
nouvelles combinaisons a déjà
coûté plus de 400 millions $
à la NASA, qui prévoit  dépenser
au total 1 milliard $.
XAVIER PASCO, directeur,
Fondation recherche stratégique
- C'est vrai que là, c'est
surprenant, parce que l'ordre
de grandeur d'1 milliard $,
c'est des ordres de grandeurs
qui correspondent au
développement de fusées,
en réalité.
- Les combinaisons actuelles
ont été conçues en 1974 pour
le programme de navettes,
puis modernisées à plusieurs
reprises. C'est une pièce
d'équipement extraordinairement
complexe, qui permet de survivre
en autonomie complète
en dépit des radiations,
des micrométéorites
et des températures extrêmes.
RICHARD BOUDREAULT, spécialiste
technologies aérospatiales
- C'est un mini vaisseau
spatial. Il faut réguler
la température. On parle
de différence de température
entre l'ombre et le soleil
d'un peu plus que 100°.
- Avec le temps, cependant,
les combinaisons vieillissent
et se détériorent.
En 2013, un astronaute a failli
mourir noyé quand le système
de refroidissement défecteux
de sa combinaison a rapidement
inondé son casque. Il a dû
rentrer à la station
en catastrophe.
Malgré ses efforts, la NASA
ne parvient toujours pas
à développer la combinaison
parfaite, plus souple et
flexible que les combinaisons
actuelles, qui permettra
aux astronautes de se déplacer
autrement qu'en bondissant,
comme durant les missions
Appolo; et surtout, d'accomplir
les tâches complexes qu'exigent
la construction et l'entretien
des futures bases spatiale
et lunaire.
- Si l'astronaute n'est pas
capable de pouvoir mettre
deux tuyaux ensemble, ça pose
un problème important. Donc,
c'est probablement un des objets
les plus compliqués à faire.
- Et puis, il y a le problème
omniprésent de l'épaisse couche
de poussière qui recouvre
la Lune, la régolite.
- La Lune, c'est un astre qui
a recu beaucoup d'astéroides.
La plupart du matériel sur
la surface de la Lune sont
des matériaux extrêmement fins,
qui enrayent presque tous
les mécanismes.
- Le problème, c'est que
le temps presse, même pour
les opérations courantes
de la NASA.
L'Agence a fabriqué
18 combinaisons spatiales
depuis 1974. Cinq ont été
détruites avec les navettes
Columbia et Challenger et
une, durant une mission de
SpaceX. Neuf sont inutilisables
ou en réparation. Les quatre
dernières se trouvent sur
la station spatiale.
L'agence américaine doit aussi
composer avec d'autres délais
liés à ses partenaires
commerciaux privés, responsables
du transport vers la Lune.
- C'est un programme qui a pris
beaucoup de retard, qui a pris
beaucoup de surcoûts.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est vrai que
des questions sont posées aux
États-unis sur l'organisation
même de la NASA et sur
l'organisation de ses activités.
- "Dans le meilleur des cas",
dit la NASA, "deux nouvelles
combinaisons seront prêtes en
2025." Ensuite, la production
de chaque nouvelle unité coûtera
200 millions $.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M